for the last six years it's come down to
a heated battle between two office
rivals who take this really seriously
there's Devon in research ok and Barbara
and makeup and yeah they these two
really this competition means everything
to them so we thought this year would
bring out our competitors and let the
audience decide
[Applause]
all right thanks Conan ladies and
gentlemen please welcome the finalists
in the 2016 Conan staff holiday sweater
pageant Devin and Barbara
[Applause]
[Music]
look at those sweaters Wow well let's
start with you Devin it looks like this
year you really brought your a-game
actually I brought my slay game hold for
laughter hold for luck holding for
laughter more I think I think that's
long enough to hold for laughter I just
wanted to honor
Santa's North Pole roots so all of the
yarn is hand spun from real polar bear
fur wow that is amazing I'm and I like
even even that you I don't know if you
can tell the little presents are all
hand knit yeah yeah that's right and
inside each one is an Olive Garden gift
card made of yarn there's a wonderfully
unnecessary detail yeah
waste of time well check this out to the
turtleneck converts into Santa's beard
Oh
I do have one more question and what is
what are those reins for I see hanging
down Andy I'm glad you asked it's my
secret weapon check it out yeah
[Applause]
it's a real live reindeer Wow
I ho ho hope you vote for me hold for
applause Barbara tell us about your
sweater here I call this sweater
my body is a winter wonderland get it
yeah I think we all get it I sewed in
dozens of miniature people skiing mount
Barbara and I've got some ice skaters
down below I know it looked cold Andy
but it gets hot pretty fast under there
at least it used to be for menopause
yeah yeah
yeah you've told us all that before
Barbara tell me about the sleeves my
nephew Zach the one born with a full set
of teeth yes yes actually well he
designed this working ski lift skiers go
up and then those skiers are going down
mm-hmm speaking of going down what are
you doing over the holidays Andy
[Applause]
yeah HR has warned you about that kind
of talk okay and oh wow
what's the cloud for there Barbara well
the forecast on Mount Barbara calls for
snow
oh you have really well there you have
it
this year's two finalists for the cone
and staff holiday sweater
what Oh
make way make way hark what is that
Christmas miracle yarn hither look
yonder for it is Conan O'Brien wearing a
full nativity scene Tony
[Applause]
[Applause]
and danger
Wow once again just like last year we
have our winner Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
you